so Rebecca and I we operate fair share
farm this is the farm we're in Northeast
Clay County Missouri North Kansas City
so that's our house
we got a bar in our new fermenting
facility high tunnel two different
fields that we operate one we tend to
use more in the spring when it because
it dries out quicker we have an
irrigation pond here and a solar panel
the irrigation system is solar-powered
we started in 2003 and first CSA season
was 2004 this year we had 130 members
our members work on the farm that's part
of the CSA operation Rebecca is a fourth
generation farmer we also have some hens
at this point and so there's our CSA
like I said we're a participatory CSA
that's kind of the traditional model our
members are required to help 2 to 3
times a year to come out with the
harvest it's one of the things and our
survey they say they actually like
almost the most about the farm we grow
40 different types of vegetables like
most CSA farms our approach
we're not certified organic and we
consider ourselves a biological farm you
know we tell people that do what we do
so we think of the soil as the plant
stomach you know you're gonna feed the
soil you grow cover crop you turned it
under the biology of the soil digests
and decomposes that matter and that's
what you feed the plant with just like
yourself you get a piece of broccoli it
goes into your body it gets digested by
the by the probiotics in your body and
we also like to say you are what you eat
so you are what your plants eat and we
feel all the cover cropping and
biological methods that we've used over
the years really helps improve the
nutrition and the flavor of the crops we
do what we feed the
soyal a balanced meal we try every year
to either give us cover crops compost or
hay mulch straw organic fertilizer and
we cover crop pretty much all year long
so we did a lot of mulching we buy
composters organization called Missouri
organics in Kansas City we can get
that's enough for about 20 beds of
20,000 foot beds about half acre we use
a fur trail super n as a organic
fertilizer that we can apply it's easy
to put down we have a one we actually
now have two moveable hen houses we like
to move them into areas where we have
cover crops growing and how to have them
use that as a food source as well as
their ration they say we grow a lot of
cover crops
this is protal area and suntanned
circumstan and grass here buckwheat we
have a electric tractor so it's an
allis-chalmers ji there's a sare grant
from a while back that from a farmer in
New York State Ron Klose he converted it
to from gas to electric you can see the
batteries on the back there it
essentially runs like a golf cart
this was our field day that we had this
year so another thing they said we've
been farming 13 years using biological
practices last year I decided to compile
all of our soil data so back in 2003 we
actually got a grant from the state of
Missouri a sustainable AG demonstration
award Joan familiar with that she signed
off on that and we were able to get
money for soil testing we got a manure
spreader and money to buy cover crop
seeds and so that kind of got us
starting started and just want to kind
of point out here you know the
whole point of organic or biological
farming is to improve soil quality if
you do that then the plants are gonna
grow so we have this first sample
there's only one I don't think it it's
really as a baseline as much assists
arted out with about 2.6 percent organic
matter on our farm and for a while every
year and then we skipped and we we just
kept taking soil samples and you can see
as time went on here we went from our
ranges being less than three in the twos
to where we get down here towards 2013
15 our ranges have gone up so you can
see we've basically raised our soil
organic matter by almost one and a half
percent and that's one thing that we're
really proud of and we like to show this
this is it a graph that this is what
organic farming can do I don't think
it's talked about enough if you look at
from like 2008 until now with the
acreage that we've grown calculated that
we've added about 250,000 pounds of
organic matter to our soil which relates
to about 350,000 pounds of carbon
dioxide that we've sequestered so that's
something that is in agriculture you can
do just kind of a matter of course we
think that's important you can see that
it kind of bounced around and went down
and then up for a while we were took
awhile a lot of years for us to really
get our cover cropping going but once we
did you can see the improvements so they
said the the biology the soil is
important and we've always kind of
wanted to do value-added but didn't
really want to slave over a stove and
make tomato sauce for people and what
we've decided to do is to do fermenting
so we like how that kind of ties the
biology of the soil to the biology to
the food to the biology of your of our
digestive systems because they're all
really the same thing
so sauerkraut obviously one fermented
food most people are familiar with
there's a Rebecca it's a little blurry
fill them some jars with kimchi in our
new kitchen and there's a facility built
on like a hundred-year-old
tobacco barn and there was a couple of
our products so that was part of the
genesis for this project we do grow some
things that are more fruiting vegetables
like cucumbers to make pickles and
jalapenos to make pickled jalapenos but
the idea was going to grow a lot of
cabbage so we want to do it the simplest
way possible the least amount of labor
and so the Rolly roller crimper
and planting into roll-down beds is
something that we wanted to work on so
it's been quite a long project
so you see here 2013 first step was to
plan triage in the winter or in the fall
so that the following spring we'd have a
crop to roll down the idea was that we
would sew crimp these down we also
trialing tomatoes in the roll down cover
crops and then in July late July plant
the fall brassicas into into that and
then in September seed the rive at for
the next year so we'll go through all
that so 2014 no-till Brassica you can
see here this is a flail mower that we
had and part of the project also was to
get us a better flail mower
that one's a little lightweight there
weren't a lot of safety guards on it but
one thing it did show is that in talking
to Ron Morris also who's our technical
adviser dr. Morris is from Virginia Tech
so you don't need to buy a roller
crimper we had that in there originally
and then we took it out to roll down to
cover crop the the flail mowers have a
very very large roller on the backhoe
very very heavy so all you really need
to do
to drag the flail mower through a bed
with out the mower going to roll down
the crops and this is what it looks like
so 2014 I'll start it out really well we
had a really nice rich crop we rolled it
down a looked like this looked really
good
the vetch came back up which isn't
unusual it's more veiny it doesn't
really have the stem like rye does it'll
just break we mowed that off at the same
time we were doing a trial so we we did
the roll down beds and then we used our
Spader and we tilled in beds and the
idea was to compare roll down production
versus tilled production mode off the
right edge but then as you can see
behind our farm crew here the bindweed
started coming in we had other areas
where the grasses started coming in so
you know we're trying Cynthia got out
here I think was maybe 75 foot I don't
know if it was even that far and it's
like okay let's just see how long it's
gonna take so it took like five hours of
personnel time to hand weed this area
and then it just came back anyway so we
tried another thing we had this organic
herbicide called Ground Force which is
it's just like a citric or acetic acid
and so we tried spraying that and then
we sprayed the whole thing and didn't
matter it just all came back it's not a
systemic herbicide it just kind of tilts
kills the top growth so the main focus
of this whole project the first year we
just had to abandon the thought of even
planting into this we did I'll show you
with the no-till planting that we did
try to run the machinery but we didn't
plant into it so no-till planting aid
it's basically a furrow er and as a
system that dr. Moore's developed and so
he helped us in building the
till planting AIDS so it's a way that
just pull furrows in the rolled down
cover crop and then you can plant into
that area so you can just look he has a
lot of literature on this you know you
can go online you can buy a toolbar you
can buy this and that and you just kind
of build it but we have this equipment
laying around the farm so it was like
well we're gonna kind of farm hack the
whole thing so we had this tool bar
which looks like it's a square of tool
bar and after I bought the clamps found
out it's actually a diamond tool bar and
then the shanks you know ones longer
than the other you saying these
Coulter's they were really too small to
use so I kind of roughed it up so these
are one of the things we bought were
these Coulter's you really need them to
be big if you have a lot of roll down
cover crop it has to be able to cut
through it this shank wasn't gonna there
just wasn't enough space there so we
really we had to get a piece of steel
and drop this straight down and then it
turned out that they're still kind of
too close we had a bolt and extension
onto that you can kind of see where this
is a square on a diamond and then you
got this little bit here and we had we
didn't cut that off the first year so it
worked it worked well just like he said
it would it dragged through you just had
a furrow going there we have a
waterwheel transplanter the idea was
weed spaced the waterwheels at that
distance and pull it through and be able
to plant but showing you those pictures
before you can see that already all this
vine weed had grown back in so last year
we couldn't do it I'll go into that this
year I kind of fixed it up a little bit
you can see here I cut that off that was
really catching on the cover crop and
and causing a problem and you can see
here the steel that's the extension we
spent money and bought a diamond clamp
so
it worked worked really well pulls right
through there you can kind of see it it
cuts down maybe eight inches into the
soil and so the no-till planting aid
worked fine our you know conclusions are
you can farm hack it and maybe save a
little bit of money or it's not that
hard to find the parts you need for a
toolbar and everything else to to make
it with new parts it's a great tool it
does what it says and we still may use
it there may be times when it's really
wet out and we don't want to till an
area and we can use this to create a
planting furrow without causing a lot of
problems so there's a Rebecca this is
one of our other field days we had a
field day each year
that same year 2014 we did the same
thing for tomatoes so the idea with the
tomatoes we only in the summer we do a
second planting two tomatoes in there we
call them our summer Tomatoes we use a
hybrid we'll cage them and so we took
this 200 foot bed that's our standard
bed length and rolled down a hundred
foot of it and then the other hundred
feet we spayed it in and planted into
that to mulch here's the tomatoes that
we hand planted in here
unfortunately we I'm still searching for
the data from this one but it was really
wet I mean when we dug the holes and put
these tomato plants in there was water
at the bottom it was it was a really wet
year so I don't know that the data from
this necessarily would have been that
good and we did the same test this year
and I have much better information from
that but you can kind of see it we did
hand weed this once and for the tomatoes
that didn't work out too bad the thing
with the tomatoes are you you roll it
down most of this happens in late May
that's when the Rye has reached the
stage where you gonna
down and the tomatoes are summer
Tomatoes will plant maybe second week of
June so it will have died back and we
can plant right into it whereas with the
Brassica as you roll it down you know
before May is over and then you're not
going to plant until the middle of July
your cabbage or something and it just
sitting there all this time and weeds
have more of a chance to grow just
wanted to go through this real quick
just to kind of show you we've done a
lot of a lot of cover cropping this is
an example we do cover crops in the
spring summer and fall
there's like a summer cover crop of
looks like mung bean or beans and and
sorghum Sudan grass so we'll let it grow
will flail mow it down that's what it
looks like when it flailed Mose is all
nice and chopped and then this is our
Spader I know if you guys ever seen a
Spader it's one of the first pieces of
equipment that we got they had one at
the farm in New York where we were it
it's a really nice piece of equipment
you can see these shovels in here so
there's like a half dozen shovels and
they actually dig the soil you can
actually go through bed say you had
potatoes in and you harvested them all
and go through and Spade and you can
find potatoes that are you know haven't
even been damaged when you're all done
spading so it's a it's not as
pulverizing as a garden type tiller
that's what it looks like on a good day
we have a silk clay soil so it's really
difficult to always find the exact
perfect soil moisture to to Spade but
that looks nice like that
you know we consider cover cropping kind
of composting in place we also have in
the past have taken the plastic off our
high tunnel and cover crop tower high
tunnel so 2015 was going to be our
second year's gonna be a two-year
project
but we suspended the project because of
rain so I don't know if you can read all
this data but you can see down here at
the bottom it was I don't this first
year I ever decided to keep like
rainfall records and just had a little
log and I kept in the notes and it was
really interesting to have done it this
year over the course of 74 days we had
almost 36 inches of rain with your
crates to almost a half an inch of rain
every day for 74 days right in here this
is about the time that you would
normally be rolling and crimping and up
till the end of May we had 10 inches and
then the first week of June we had 10
inches just in in those couple days we
also had hail so this you can kind of
see this is a total precipitation for
that day and we're right in the middle
of the worst of it
so this is what strawberries look like
after they've been pummeled by hail like
Rebecca said it looks like little tiny
fairy punches on them and and when you
count on your strawberries and they're
just ripening and you get hail it's no
fun and so we're trying to keep the
project going too but like you could see
there was really no time period when
this was ready to be rolled down that we
could get in there and I was doing
everything I could work on this project
and keep the rest of the farm going and
there are a few times when I probably
went out went out there when I shouldn't
have so that was a lesson all in and of
itself this is more of the rain that we
had so we skipped 2015 and got into 2016
so one of the other parts of this
project was to evaluate our cover
cropping method we had always just done
broadcast seeding and harrowing
that's how we would do our cover
cropping and you've seen some of those
pictures things worked out fine but it's
pretty labor-intensive so the idea was
to get a cedar and I spent almost two
years looking for a used grain drill
like six foot wide and I had absolutely
no luck finding one
so eventually decided to go to getting a
vegetable cedar
so our allis-chalmers G we have a tool
bar and we have three planet junior
cedars and we concede with that just off
the electric tractor so the thought was
if I can get four new planet juniors I
could put that on the allis-chalmers and
we could use our electric tractor to do
our cover cropping but turns out once
the cedars came that these are newer
ones and they're like twice the weight
of the other ones so that didn't really
work out so we had to get a tool bar so
that we could just pull it behind our
our farm all so these are vegetable
cedars and we're trying to see cover
crops but you know for the most part
seeds or seeds so we've started looking
at well you know what's the seed plate
for a rye or vetch or whatever and so
one way to do it was simply to measure
the circumference of the front wheel
which would be the ground tracking on it
open up the cedar and just spin the
wheel for so many feet and count how
many pounds fell out and then we could
calculate okay well this wheel will get
you so many pounds per acre or per bed
whatever we wanted so I did that and
every like this hopper it looks like
these both had like vets in them and
those two might have had rye these were
offset so we wanted eight rows so I had
to kind of turn around and go back down
the other way and try and have the cedar
go in between the other rows so that
didn't work out all that great it worked
out okay and then the other thing was
having two different seeds and two
different seed holes and trying to keep
all that perfect really was kind of a
pain so when I went to just mixing the
seed and you just use the largest seed
hole and you calibrate it that way so
you mix the Ryan batch or the oats and
peas or the Sudan grass and crota larrya
together whatever it is you need and you
find the seed where you get we're trying
to get about about two pounds or so per
thousand foot bed so that you can see
here OOP we got one two three four five
like six rows here this is a bed so you
really want like eight so it wasn't too
bad
grew pretty well the the peas were
supposed to be separate inside there and
some of those work some didn't so for
the next time I did it I tried putting
it all to one side figuring at least I'd
make sure everything was on one side or
on each side this was this summer and
some of that didn't turn out that well
because it got very dry for a while and
the seeds just sat there and so the
wheats started to take over but this is
part of the trial where this area here
was broadcast and Harrow it in and these
were with the cedar and it pretty much
looked like that we'd cut areas and way
um and so we did this two different
times and so you can see from the top
one the first time we did it and a
spring crop the cedar had a little bit
better weight and then when we measured
in the fall from one of the summer
plantings the broadcast had a better
weight we took like a four by four area
just cut it down and weight it
we kept using it it does the cedar it
does give you a pretty good stand that
doesn't always look like it at the start
these are peas and oats
and this just interesting is so warm
this year this is actually a sunhemp
flower which we'd never seen before
because it's just been growing all year
all winter long or fall along so we feel
vegetable cedar can be used to seed
cover crops it's a multi-use cedar then
if you have more than one use for it if
your vegetable farmer we would advise
combining two C types into the and use
the larger cedar hole the one for the
larger seed and then you can just have
all your cedars at the same cedar hole
we had a little difficult to get like
eight perfectly spaced rows and
harrowing can be just as effective as
the cedar it just takes a lot more
effort so this is our second try at the
no-till Brassica that was this this is
this year so last September we put down
rive at that was a really really wet
year and for some reason you can see
there's hardly any rye that came up but
we had a lot of edge so that's what it
looked like in May we rolled down the
veg we that's a picture of the new flail
mower you can kind of see that roller
there that just helps roll stuff down
and this is one of the trial beds and
pretty much the same thing happened you
know the where we are I mean I'll out
here it's a lot of grassland and like
between the end of May and then you have
all of June and going into July that's
when grasses really really want to grow
this area we'd never put down hay or
anything it was a relatively new area
that we were like the second year we
used it but when you have to wait around
that long before you plant at least for
us you just get too much weed pressure
especially from the grasses so it's easy
to roll down with the flail mower
there's a problem because of the weed
pressure from the grasses in the heat of
the summer
you saw the wet periods we had it's
really hard to implement the roller
crimper and planting in it during the
wet periods and we tried doing like hand
weeding and everything and that really
is not an effective way to kind of make
up for any any problems that you might
have this is more rain so this year at
the end of August we had 10 inches over
a couple days and four inches a couple
weeks later so there was still a lot of
this this year so these are the summer
tomatoes so this is the same thing as
showing you before we grew a cover crop
one area we mowed it and spaded it in
the other one we rolled it this is what
it looked like right after we were done
with that you can see there's hay on the
Left we we mainly use hay we're able to
get hay off of Rebecca's family land
next door the one on the right is the
rolled down so things started out
pretty good both of them these are
Delarosa I believe or the tomato type
they're summer tomato this is once they
really started going I don't know if you
can really tell but this the the hay
mulched ones were really a deeper green
they're a better stand then over here we
weeded these once but after that it was
like well they're kind of on their own
that's the point we don't want to be
spending a lot of time weeding no it's
like what type of question was what you
know what type of hay and it was like a
lot of broom there's some clover in
there but yeah it wasn't native we may
be able to get native soon her father
just seeded a lot of switchgrass all
over the farm so maybe in the future so
this year we had a lot of you know the
fruit was really great there was a
problem when they weave
first started going out to harvest our
irrigation had kind of we had some
complications with it for awhile and the
kind of the first fruits that we were
picking had a lot of blossom end rot got
the irrigation working we watered a lot
and that kind of went away and this is
the data from this year so you can see
here that once with the hay mulch had
three times the yield that the rolled
ones did they both had a decent amount
of fruit set but the hay mulched ones
had had a lot more first this is mainly
first at least first trying to come out
the field so both of the roller crimper
like I said they keep down the weeds
because you're going to plant in them
right pretty much right away so it's a
much better situation we are maybe
considering trying this for the summer
tomatoes a different year and then
mulching rolled down areas right away
and that might really eliminate weeds
and maybe then rolled down crops they'll
get a little more digested you know that
top growth if you don't spayed it in it
doesn't really get digested you don't
get as much nutrient release so part of
it is there just wasn't as much in the
soil but spaded in hay mulch beds if you
can get a good spading seem to work as
well as anything so these are some of
the costs so the no-till planting aid
with us you already having a tool bar
and a few things was about eleven
hundred bucks a flail mower I was able
to find online actually came out here to
Kansas somewhere to pick it up and then
the coal cedar with the hitch was a
little over four thousand dollars so
sorry there's not more data about what
we planted but it did demonstrate to us
that you know we tried and try it it's
not necessarily a system that's gonna
work in our area in our soils
for us
did you ever get rid of the bindweed no
well it's funny the wet year we hardly
saw any bindweed on the farm and we
didn't really have as much this year as
we had two years ago went when I shown
you that we applied Rebecca applied for
a permit from USDA to buy these buying
weed mites have you heard about them at
all
so there's supposedly there are these
mites that only attack buying weed and
somewhere out in Colorado you can buy
them so she had like go through this
whole process and you know it's like if
you know same type of paperwork if
you're gonna transfer smallpox across
state lines you know and so she applied
for it and we were gonna do it the next
year but because of all the rain we
didn't do it I had bindweed problem and
cattles worked wonderful yeah I mean
they cleaned it out my only concern was
were they gonna carry seed elsewhere but
they digest the seed
I had no spreading so hanging it would
be an option if you can find somebody
that's willing to buy hay with fine weed
in it mm-hmm
yeah we're hoping maybe the chickens
might do something to it too but we
don't know yet have you guys ever tried
anything with like on your cover crop
having an edible mixed in with the cover
crop for us oh yeah like as a cash crop
no well I guess I shouldn't say that we
kind of we're growing daikons so we
until each radishes and we're doing the
fermenting and right now we're kind of
trying there's some varieties from
Johnny and other places that are really
more culinary and I've tried the till
eat radishes but right now the batch
that we did is really has a lot of
bitterness to it and I suppose if we I
mean it if you plant a whole bed of them
you can
pull up you know hundred pounds and
you're not gonna lose a lot but the
whole idea the cyllage radishes to leave
it in the ground and then otherwise we
don't have a combine you know if we did
we'd probably ever get a lot of
buckwheat because buckwheat like seeds
it you know almost right away
you